it wasn't like this when i came here
before
hey guys pete here it's show time folks
we're here to talk about nippy the 10th
episode in better call saul's final
season and this video will contain
spoilers if you haven't watched it yet
this was an episode where i experienced
so many different things during this
trip back to omaha as a person who pays
as much attention to this series as a
person can i came in with some
expectations because the last episode
worked as a conclusion to the jimmy
mcgill timeline it seemed like anything
was possible almost anything except what
we actually got with three episodes left
to go i would have never guessed that we
might see a conclusion to gene's problem
with jeff the cab driver that seemed
like it was all set up for the end of
the series and yet here we are this made
for a situation where i added my own
additional layer of tension on top of
what i was watching on the screen as it
went on i kept expecting some big shift
to happen was it gonna turn back to
color will we get one of those quick
cuts and be right back in the breaking
bad timeline after all didn't they say
that jesse and walt were gonna come back
in this episode something felt off in
this beautifully shot story of a scammer
operating at the top of his game it
dripped unease and it wasn't so much of
a question of why am i watching this but
maybe something more like why am i
watching this now
it turned out to be a great way for the
creators to toy with those expectations
i mentioned earlier and i wouldn't say
that it was a satisfying episode because
it did leave me wanting more but it was
a fun break from all the heaviness we
experienced in the past few episodes and
it left me fascinated about what might
come next the last time we saw gene
takovic was in the season 5 premiere
that aired way back on february 23
in the previous season he had been
identified by jep the cab driver who
picked him up from the hospital after he
fainted on his shift managing the
cinnabon the paranoia they built up over
each of his brief appearances in the
series boiled over when jeff returned to
the mall and looked gene up his secret
was out and he thought about running
again but changed his mind telling ed to
disappear that he would fix it himself
that's exactly what he does in nippy his
plan starts with him earning the
confidence of jeff's mother who is
played by the legendary carol burnett
there's a quick sequence at the grocery
store that hints that she might be more
formidable than her son which might turn
out to be important later i'll come back
around to that but then we see gene pull
off some of his jimmy mcgill magic he
puts some snow on marion's path so
she'll get stuck in a place where she'll
notice the missing posters he's hanging
up for his dog nippy the story opens the
door to her accepting his help and gives
him the chance to snip the wires on her
scooter when he pushes it that leads to
him helping her all the way home and
they're sharing stories and schnapps by
the time jeffy gets there he has to sit
through an uncomfortable dinner before
he can get gene alone and try to get the
upper hand back it's already too late
though just as gene threw his story
about sammy hagar back in his face he
uses the way that things played out
against him jeff hasn't turned him in or
tried to blackmail him yet so gene
offers him something better a chance to
get in the game he sells it by saying
it's about knowing all the angles
putting it all on the line in winning
and you watch the change on jeffy's face
as he's reeled in i guess i should
mention that this is a different actor
playing jeff they did have to recast
this role because the original actor don
harvey was under contract with we own
the city at the same time the portrayal
is a little different but i think the
new actor pat healy did a great job if
you're really having a hard time with it
maybe just think about the dynamic of
him being around his mother because she
seems like she runs things in that house
i also thought it felt like bob odenkirk
found a new layer for his character in
this scene not gene but not exactly saul
or jimmy either he's there to pull jeff
in but still jabs at him using his own
words enough to make it sting later he
tells him here's the deal i will show
you the game and then we're done and
from there we see him put together his
multi-part plant and just to get into
the spirit of things he pulls out
marco's pinky ring and wears it for the
duration of this scam phase one is to
make friends with the nighttime security
guards and find out how long he can
distract the one who's watching the
cameras by giving him free cinnabun it's
a lot of fun to watch as gene works his
way in here the first guard remembers
him telling the shoplifter to call a
lawyer back in season three you see how
he lightens up a little with each
cinnamon roll gene makes friends with
his partner who is the real mark since
he's the one he has to distract from the
monitors he throws himself into research
in college football after just echoing
his reactions to the game in their first
conversation there's been a question
about if the gene timeline happens in
2010 or 2011. while they're talking they
mention a martinez setting a freshman
record and that's something that really
happened in october of 2010. saul used
ed to disappear from albuquerque in
april of that year which means he's been
living as gene for about six months if
you're one of those people who were
holding out hope that walter white might
still be alive in the gene timeline this
should put that to rest since he died in
september phase two is to go to the
mall's department store lancasters and
locate the most expensive items that
jeff could grab in the time it takes
frank to savor his nightly treat you see
gene counting the steps from the
different items much like gus did with
his gun in the lab but here he isn't
planning to find something in the dark
he's planning on making a training
course he runs jeff around that while
shouting a rhyme he's come up with to
help him remember what to grab over a
bullhorn and there isn't any question
that this is a very well thought out
plan still it seems crazy to jeff and
gene has to pull out the story of walter
white to motivate him to continue he
leaves out all the terrible stuff that
happened and just says i'll tell you
what's crazy 50 year old high school
chemistry teacher comes into my office
the guy is so broke he can't pay his own
mortgage one year later he's got a pile
of cash as big as a volkswagen phase
three is to get jeff into the building
inside a wooden crate that can then
later be used to stash the loot until
the next morning he sweet talks the
store manager when she calls to complain
and then everything is set when frank
starts eating his cinnabon gene texts
jeff that it's time to go he comes out
of the crate and does just as he
rehearsed on the practice field until he
runs into a snag there was a scuff mark
on the floor so the manager kathy had
called to have it cleaned up and when
jeff ran across it he slipped and fell
he actually knocked himself out so gene
has to think on his feet because frank's
almost done eating and he always
immediately turns around to check the
monitors where he would be able to
clearly see jeff lying motionless in the
middle of the store he does something
that we've seen him do before he starts
to spin a tale that is mostly based in
truth he starts to cry saying that his
parents are dead his brother is dead he
has no wife no kids no friends and all
of this makes you think of chuck and kim
and it's pretty heavy you know that on
some level it's just an act but in a way
this is the most emotion he's shown
about chuck's death he's built up enough
of a rapport that frank is sympathetic
and i thought it was a nice touch that
when he asks him if he knows what he
means he's like no not me because that
shows that it might be awkward enough
that it wouldn't be weird if gene no
longer comes to visit anymore it works
long enough to give jeff time to get up
and to go hide in the bathroom until the
morning we see him sneak out as the
delivery worker comes to pick up the
crate and it looks like they're gonna
get away with it
jeff and his friend are pumped up but
gene brings them some bad news he tells
them all of the crimes that they've
committed and explains the concept of
mutually assured destruction they can no
longer threaten to turn him in because
if he goes down he'll take them with him
as he's driving this home he echoes
their first meeting in the mall when he
says say it and tells them they're not
friends they're done and not to come
back looking for more they seem to
understand that they've lost and there's
one more close call when marion comes
home where jean is able to pretend like
he's fixing the car to create a cover
story he helps her inside with her
groceries and she explains that she's
happy that he's in jeff's life because
he fell in with a bad crowd in
albuquerque and she thinks that he's
doing better now that he has him in his
life she also asks him about nippy and
it almost catches him off guard he tells
her that he got him back and he says the
line we heard a few weeks ago in the
teaser trailer after all that a happy
ending from there we see him go back to
work and he looks alive again we've seen
him do this so many times in those cold
open teasers but here he is actually
smiling he's so into it he almost
forgets to go to lunch but when reminded
he goes over to lancaster's and you can
see that he knows that they got away
with it you see him with a look on his
face where it's almost as if he's
impressed with himself and how he's able
to pull this off without any unintended
consequences he looks around the store
he picks up a loud shirt and tie combo
he holds it up and looks at himself in
the mirror and then he puts it down and
walks away as the episode comes to an
end so my initial thought was that even
though this is a great episode of better
call saul that continued to deliver the
inevitable in a way we couldn't quite
predict i was so perplexed that he
pulled everything off that it almost
seemed like there was something missing
as i went back and re-watched to put
these notes together knowing what would
happen it stood out just how true to
what we've seen for six seasons this was
it may have been in black and white and
we may have gotten the answer to how
he'd take down jeff but what's more
exciting is that feeling of not knowing
what comes next we heard most of the
remaining sound bites from those
mid-season break teaser trailers we got
a classic scam quite a few laughs a nice
split screen montage and enough
references to reward us for paying
attention that it almost seemed like a
reset but if that's the case seriously
where do we go from here this isn't how
i would choose the end jeans story but
it could certainly feel like an ending
if we didn't know there were three more
episodes there are two choices that
stand out to me here the first is that
he got away with the scam and out from
under jeff clean in my last couple of
videos i've been talking about addiction
as it relates to jimmy and kim and their
scamming in sobriety they say the drink
or drug that will take you down is the
one you get away with because that gives
you the false sense that you don't need
to abstain even though it remains in
black and white it's almost like you can
see the color come back into his life at
the end but then he puts the saul s
closed down and walks away this episode
shows that he'll never be happy as gene
but also hasn't slipped completely into
his old ways either that could mean that
he'll take on a brand new persona but
i'm not sure what problem he needs to
solve other than he's living a boring
paranoid life and there's not much he
can do about the second part of that
restraint isn't an option it's necessary
so if he can have a taste and walk away
from it what does that say about his
character at this point in the story the
other decision that stood out was to
cast carol burnett as jeff's overbearing
but ultimately harmless mother it would
be fine if that was all they asked her
to do watching her spit out the
wisconsin extra sharp cheddar that had
writer producer tom schnauz's name
attached to it was one of many great
little moments but i don't know because
in that final scene in the kitchen i
kept expecting her to turn on gene it
would be hilarious if she tried to turn
his life upside down for what he did to
her jeffy there could be an epic
showdown there to end the series the two
actors were great working together so it
feels like there's more potential there
if they decided to go that route this is
all informed by the fact that i think
making him face what he's done makes the
most sense for the character's ending
i've wanted to believe that there was
some jimmy still inside there after the
events of breaking bad and this episode
showed that at least the part where he
can make people like him when he needs
to is there if the good parts are there
too then there's a chance at redemption
but it seems like it has to come be a
reckoning of the harm he caused and
looking at some of the things that he's
kept buried could marian force him to
move in that direction if she makes his
life complicated does it make more sense
for it to be something related to kim
and how will walt and jesse making an
appearance fit in these are great
questions to have because this is the
only show that i can imagine putting me
in a place to absolutely have no idea at
the end of the day it feels like a flex
because it seems like they had an idea
that was so good that they thought this
was the best way to go about it and i
want to know what that is i can't wait
to find out and i think that is a good
place to leave things join us for the
live stream on tuesday night at 9 pm
eastern time we'll get into more of what
we're thinking about after we had a
little bit of time let me know in the
comments what you thought about this
episode where you think things are going
what stood out to you the most was it
marion was it jimmy shedding a tear
while he was talking about chuck or was
it seeing him put the clothes back up on
the rack and walk away please like this
video if you enjoyed it please subscribe
to my channel if you haven't already and
thanks for watching i'll talk to you
soon
you